news voice is the world's first mobile
app that helps you track
where your news is coming from news
voice helps you track what corporate
interests might be influencing the
narratives in the news you read every
day
arm yourself against corporate media
monopolies by
downloading the news voice app for free
using the link right underneath this
video
let's try once more i'm going to give
them one other opportunity
diego from mexico is back i don't know
what happened the first time
diego are you with us uh yes can you
hear me
david i can hear you yes oh thank you
i thought my discord didn't work um it
works beautifully
yeah well it's the david pakman show
discord um
my question is about the star the stock
market and the recent plunge because
the news that trump is going to halt
well halted all negotiations like
i i can't understand what's the
political plague here like
i don't think there is one no i think i
think he i think he's on uh i think he's
on roid rage from the dexamethasone it
makes no sense and you know diego the
thing was
when when this all happened on tuesday
first
trump tweets no second stimulus and the
stock market crashes
then the stock market closes and at
night
donald trump tweets if they get me a
bill to sign to send twelve hundred
dollar checks to people
i'll sign it and we'll send the checks
and then wednesday
the stock market goes up for 400 points
intraday
i don't know that donald trump you know
in general i question how stable donald
trump is mentally
right now he seems particularly unstable
and it may be because of the medications
he's on but you're completely right
sending checks to people is the la it's
the hail mary it's the last chance
trump has to try to win some votes back
why would he abandon it it makes no
sense
exactly even uh right right leading
paul rasmussen has him down i believe 12
points
yeah and the only explanation i've heard
is that
he's taking the country hostage and
saying if i
don't win you can't even get the
stimulus right because of the
lame duck period uh so even then you
have to wait the only way you can get
a relief soon is if you vote for me but
i don't know
well the crazy thing about this is that
although it's true that if biden wins
trump probably won't do any stimulus
during the lame duck just despite people
in the long run biden is likely to
in total do something better for the
average person than whatever trump is
dangling now so it's not it's it's a
threat and of course people will have to
figure out what to do for the next four
months
but in the longer term if biden does win
people will be much better off
exactly i i can't even i can't even see
it from
uh trump's side but it makes no sense
yeah
yeah well uh thank you for taking
michael and
salud mexico all right very much saludos
and
appreciate the call hope to speak to you
soon that's diego
from mexico